[Music]  Selena Gomez all glammed up on Monday  night to celebrate her friend Elise  Robertson's birthday fell looking  gorgeous in this black floor-length gown  with silver detailing francia raisa and  a sparkly mini and the birthday girl and  a skin-tight white dress  the newly 25 year old documented the  group getting ready and heading to the  nice guy in Los Angeles where get this  it was a surprise -  [Applause]  I think people are gonna be a little  surprised for a comes just after  Selena's own low-key birthing though a  source tells ET the singer has another  party on Wednesday after the bash and I  witnessed lzt the weekend picked her up  from the venue they headed to the Sunset  Tower hotel together for an hour before  leaving everything you know my first my  life and my family and the friends I've  just I'm a really happy place I'm good  [Music]